réchauffement climatique
sont déjà perceptleles
et l'écoanxiété grandit.
- Plus que ça continue, plus
donné, c'est sûr qu'on pourra
pas vivre mmmme ça.
- Je peux faire des trucs de
bord, mais ça va techniquement
- Vraiment, en ce moment, les
plusieieux puis les anciennes
générations qui nous dirigent,
il faudrait vraiment prendre
- Et ce n'est la tenue de grande
moment qui leur donne espoir.
- C'est un gros événement, v v r
les choses, je suis pas sûre.
- Justin Trudeau, il est pas là.
Je sais pas, le fait qu'il ne
soit pas là, je me dis, c'e'e'ee
juste un show.
- Je la partage,
cette écoanxiété, aussi.
- Léa Ilardo milite EnEnEnEnEnEe
a marché aux côtés de centaines
de milliers de jeunes dans
les rues de Montréal.
Aujourd'hui, eysysysysysysysysys
climatiques à la Fondation
David Suzuki et sa vision des
COP a changé.
LÉA ILclclclclclclclclclclclclci
- Mes attentes vis-à-vis des
COP, elles sont beaucoup
moindres, en fait, que ce que
vraiment hyper impliquée
et qu'on voyait ça de loin.
On pense que c'est le moment
dans l'année où il va se passer
rapoort au climat, mais il faut
vraiment peut-être relativi
nos attentes. Tout n'est pas
est terminée.
- S'il en résulte souvent des
le travail se fait tout au long
de l'année et ce n'est surtout
estime Léa Ilardo.
- On peut avoir très peur
jamais trop tard, en fait pour
chaque degré de réchauffement
ça qu'à mon avis, les COPS
montrent.
l'écoanxiété augmente
constamment. Les chercheurs
qui s'intéressent au phénomène
constatent une hausse importante
chez les jeunes,
femmes.
CATHERINE RAYMOND,ogogogogogue
chercheuse dép. psychologie UQAM
- Le fait d'être exposé à autant
de changementssososososososososs
nouvelles, les médias sociaux,
etc., çaaiaiaiaiaiment venir
nous toucher, parce que ça
redéfinit nos perspectives
d'avmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmme
submergé par cette détresse?
e e e e e des mouvements qui sot
très concrets au quotidien,
ça peut nous aider grandement.éu
un adolescent qui présente del'e
d'aidr l'enfant à faire
ces gestes-là.
kilomètres de Charm el-Cheikh, t
abord et avant tout sur nos
petits gestes que nous avo
rappelle Catherine Raymond.
Ici Kim Vermette, Radio-Canada,
Montréa